il y a quelques instants encore j'avais
un chef d'entreprise au téléphone qui
regroupe les demandes de nombreux
acteurs économiques les boulangers ça a
été dit mais également l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques qui aujourd'hui ne
comprennent pas
l'absence de vision stratégique du
gouvernement pour venir en aide et en
soutien quand vous parlez de
280 euros c'est grosso modo jusqu'à
350% d'augmentation par rapport à des
prix récents quand et comment les
acteurs économiques peuvent-ils tous
subir cette concurrence le risque et
vous le savez c'est d'avoir un mur de
cessation d'activité par de faillite
monsieur le ministre
vous avez il y a peu expliqué que vous
souhaitiez parler aux fournisseurs
d'énergie ben écoutez vous en avez un
qui est tout trouvé sous la main et que
vous contrôlez entièrement il s'appelle
EDF donc mettez-vous au travail et
rapidement pour apporter des solutions
je rappelle je rappelle que pour EDF
nous payons ici les choix funeste menés
depuis 10 ans pour arrêter la production
d'électricité nucléaire on en paye très
charmant le prix
24 milliards d'euros en 2022 43
milliards en 2023 l'échec commode de
gouvernement sauteraient dangereux vous
le savez financé par de la dette mal
calibrée complexe dans leur exécution
insuffisant toujours insuffisant à
défaut de solutions structurelle vous
arrosez le sable avec de l'eau la
solution structurelle elle est
européenne car nous sommes aujourd'hui
prisonniers de l'architecture européenne
du prix d'électricité liant électricité
gaz charbon madame la ministre l'état de
guerre a pulvérisé le marché énergétique
la disparition du gaz russe la
déséquilibrer profondément et
probablement définitivement il faut donc
tirer les conséquences de cet état de
fait et abolir immédiatement les
mécanismes de concurrence qui génèrent
l'architecture du prix de conseils
européens en Conseil européen nous ne
voyons rien venir nous ne voyons rien
bouger alors certes sur le territoire
national les véhicules électriques
progressent plus 46% d'immatriculation
en 2021 mais 80% de ces véhicules sont
importés et la presse ne s'y trompe pas
elle écrit d'ailleurs le loup chinois
est dans la bergerie en effet la Chine
c'est 50% de la valeur totale d'un
véhicule électrique c'est 75 % de la
chaîne de valeur des batteries c'est 90%
des moteurs électriques produits dans le
monde et face à tout ça l'industrie
européenne étant très grande difficulté
elle ne parvient même plus à pénétrer le
marché chinois alors dans cette bataille
qui vient de commencer monsieur le
ministre quelles sont nos armes
avez-vous choisi une guerre de position
et donc de continuer à subir les assos
chinois ou entendez-vous sortir de notre
tranchée et lancer une guerre de
mouvement en octobre dernier devant la
plateforme automobile vous avez dit
qu'il fallait pas le se laisser envahir
et qu'il fallait réserver les aides à
des véhicules produits en Europe c'est
ce que vous a proposé le Sénat nous
avons ici adopté un amendement qui
venait de diminuer de 500 millions ses
aides qui sont versées essentiellement
aux industriels chinois vous l'avez
retiré c'était pourtant à mesure deux
souveraineté et qui venait aussi à
améliorer notre déficit budgétaire et
vous ne l'avez pas gardé c'est bien
dommage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]